I feel like women should hit on men more
hit on us ladies you can say whatever
you want to a guy hi an old lady
approached me once she goes ooh I'm
gonna kidnap you I was like wow I could
never say that to a woman
said to a lady she calls the police I
would be curious to know what a woman
could say that would offend me like all
right I'm gonna take you home drug you
take advantage of you and film it I'd be
like all right well at least let me pay
for the Uber
our next guest is New Orleans native but
now resides in New York City where he is
taking the comedy scene by storm and I
can't believe what I'm gonna get ready
to read I know this is a new intro for
us this is he claims to have been a
bedwetter as a kid even as an adult
comedian Mark Norman stand up as
anything but dry and you can see for
yourself this weekend at Side Splitters
but first he's here with us I gotta say
I knew you were a cell phone hey don't
let yourself I didn't know if we were uh
paid a little it happens well that was
perfect for the intro then yeah on your
behalf that letter until I was 14.
brutal brutal yeah a lot of ruined
mattresses it looked like a coffee
filter uh yeah but I'm over it now I'm
good okay that's good well one thing
that I've been able to kind of pick up
is you do have that old
humor which I do enjoy in a comedian I
do hate myself
uh I'm always drawn to people that hate
me I guess because we have so much in
common
but uh
I think most Comics should be a little
self-deprecating it'd be weird if I was
like I'm great I'm amazing you know so
you got to make fun of yourself a little
well tell us a little bit about yourself
I wanted to hear about life growing up
in New Orleans it seems like such a cool
area of the country very different than
I think most others very different it's
pretty Lawless down there very boozy uh
all my friends are you know pieces of
garbage
and I I love it there you go back down
there and you slip right back in you're
like I love a cocktail at 9 00 a.m and
I'll uh chasing alligators down there
too yeah yeah no that's all silly I mean
if alligators is code for drugs
it's a weird place it's it feels like
it's stuck in the past and that's how
people like it you know it's just you go
there yeah yeah you kick back you say a
racial slur and you get a margarita
go try to go here is not as I can
right now my news feed and Facebook is
filled with everything dealing with the
Nike's new app oh yeah what I like about
you you're not really saying sides
you're just making jokes about that's
all I do I don't have any political I
Got No Agenda I just I'm a comic I'm a
joke guy so I throw a joke out there and
I I get the hell out of there there were
some good jokes though
yeah say thanks what was it I said every
new Nike should come with one knee pad
but that's you know clear nobody gets
hurt no one gets hurt but now on your
podcast though you kind of throw the
whole PC thing out the window oh yeah
the podcast is filthy it's not for the
uh light of heart then though the PC is
so all over us now you can't stand you
guys know you can't say anything
interesting you know you're scared to
bring up the Nike thing yeah you're
nervous there I don't know how you guys
live like this because it just oozes out
of me you know I'm a horrible human big
I just farted and uh that's the first
hearing aid on our show so you know I
kill like I'm a cow I could I have to
tell the truth I can't live like that so
uh yeah it's just fun it's fun to just
get it out there what is your podcast
about what are the it's Tuesday days
Tuesdays with stories I like it so me
and my friend Joe list he goes on the
road I go on the road I think he's in
South Carolina I'm in Tampa and then we
come back on Monday we say everything
who we had sex with who got heckled who
got drunk who did drugs and uh you come
back and talk about it man it sounds
like you have to hit your game in every
city yeah have stories for the podcast I
want all good things from Tampa though
oh this is a this place is specifically
the morning blend well you know you
mentioned your friends a few times I
mean you really are friends with it
seems like the who's who of Comedy scene
these days it's a small community though
it is we're all degenerates and weirdos
and creeps and drunks and uh we're like
Pirates we need each other we're I could
never work in like a real professional
setting I'd get fired immediately and
metude and the whole thing so uh yeah we
need we're all weird and awkward and
analyzy so we have to hang out together
you guys are very normal here's the
thing we have voices in our head that's
telling us we have to go to break right
now so that's how weird we are all right
we're coming in today but it's much
worse of course you can check them out
at Side Splitters for yourself there's
the information on your screen